يومكم واهلا بكم الى هذه النشره الاخباريه
من العربيه اكد المرصد السوري ارتفاع قتل
الزلزال في سوريا الى
561 مشيرا الى الحصيله مرشحه لارتفاع حيث
ان مئات الجثث لا زالت عالقه تحت الانقاض
ولم تصلها فرق لانقاذ حتى الان في سياق
ذاته اكد المدير العام لمنظمه الصحه
العالميه تادروس ادانوب ان المنطقه التي
تثير اعلى مستويات القلق حاليا هي شمال
غرب سوريا موضحا ان نظام صحي هش بصوره
هائله والناس يعيشون جاحما
من جهه قالت شبكه السوريه لحقوق الانسان
ان تاخر وصول المساعدات الاماميه لمتضررين
الزلزال شمل غربي سوريا تسبب في زياده عدد
الضحايا مطالبه بضروره ارسال فرق تقييم
الكوارث في اسرع وقت لانقاذ ما يمكن
انقاذه وذكرت شبكه الحقوقيه في تقرير ان
استجابه الامم المتحده لم تكن بالشكل الذي
يتناسب مع هول الزلزال في شمال غرب سوريا
حيث تركت المنظمات المدنيه المحليه تواجه
بمفردها اهوال زلزال ومخلفاته
الى مطار حلب في سوريا تتجه الطائره
الاغاثيه السعوديه الثالثه ضمن الجسر
الاغاثه لدعم المتضررين جراء الزلزال
وتحمل طائره متنها 34 طنا من اجهزه
الاكسجين والسلال الغذائيه وحليب الاطفال
والمواد الطبيه افاد مراسل العربيه ان
مجموعه شحنات التي ارسلتها السعوديه
باتجاه مطار حلب بلغ قرابه 114 طنا من
المستلزمات الطبيه والاجهزه الكهربائيه
وخيام الايواء وغذاء للاطفال بجانب السلال
الغذائيه
رصدت كاميرا العربيه جانبا من حركه مرور
بعض المساعدات الامميه التي دخلت من معبر
باب الهوى الحدودي لسوريا حيث دخلت اثنتان
وعشرون شاحنه محمله بالمساعدات الانسانيه
المقدمه من الامم المتحده
[موسيقى]
في الحقيقه تستمر يستمر دخول الوافدين من
تركيا الى سوريا وفق قرار الاجازه الذي
يسمح بدخول السوريين حاملي بطاقه الحمايه
المؤقته
الصادره عن الولايات التي اصابها الضرر
والتي تدمرت في
تركيا يعني لحد هذه اللحظه اخر رقم اخذناه
من اداره معبر باب الهوى هو 1500 شخص
دخلوا الى هذا المعبر وبعد ان اخذنا هذه
الاحصائيه تم رصدنا دخول خمسه حافلات تقل
المزيد من الاشخاص
السوريين طبعا هناك العديد من التسهيلات
والاجراءات التي تنفذ من قبل الطرفين
الطرف التركي والطرف السوري هنا في سوريا
يعني كما تشاهدون خلفي على الشاشه تجري
الاجراءات في تبع الهجره والجوازات ليتم
بعدها نقل هؤلاء المسافرين عبر باصات
المعبر الى محيط مدينه سرمدا ومن هناك يتم
استقبال الوافدين من قبل الاهاليهم ومن
ليس لديه ماوى يعني تعمل يعمل اشخاص من
مختلف الفرق والمنظمات ووزاره التنميه هنا
على تامين ماوى لهم ولو كان مؤقتا
بعد توقفها سته ايام سمح النظام السوري
بدخول قافله من مئه شاحنه تحمل الوقود
وكانت مقدمه للاداره الذاتيه كمساعدات
لحلب وذلك عبر معبر التائهه الفاصل بين
مناطق سيطره طرفين
بعد ان بقيت عالقه هنا في معبر التائهه
لمده اسبوع كامل ها هي هذه الشاحنات المئه
المحمله بالوقود والمخصصه للمنكوبين في
مناطق حلب بالتحرك نحو مناطق النظام وبعد
ذلك بعد الوصول الى توافق بين الاداره
الذاتيه ونظام السوري تم بموجبه السماح
لهذه الشاحنات بالتحرك والدخول الى
المناطق الخاضعه للسيطره النظام وفق
المعلومات المتوفره لدينا فان نظام سيقوم
بتوزيع 60 الشاحنه منها على المتضررين في
مناطق مختلفه من حلب بينما ستتولى الاداره
الذاتيه بتوزيع اربعين شاحنه 30 شاحنه في
مخيم الشهباء الذي يضمه عشرات الالاف من
نازحين مدينه عفرين وعشر شاحنات اخرى في
حي الشيخ مقصود وبالتالي تكون الاداره
الذاتيه
النظام قد تواصلا الى تفاهم مبدئي يتيح
بحركه عبور المساعدات من معبر التائهه
الذي يفصل بين مناطق سيطره الطرفين في
مدينه منبج السوريه وينهي فصلا من فصول
اغلاق المعابر الداخليه بين الاطراف
المتصارعه على المشهد السوري من معبر
التائهه في مدينه منبج مع عكاش لقناتي
العربيه والحدث
لا تزالوا بلده جنديرس في عفرين شمال غرب
سوريا تعاني من اثار الزلزال المدمر الذي
حل بها قبل عشره ايام ان جون من اهالي
البلده يحاولون ادراك حجم الكارثه التي
حلت بهم مطالبين بغاثتهم وتقديم المساعدات
العاجله لهم
فوق تلال من الركام ينتظر وحيدا واستحاله
من الصدمه والالم انه من جنديرس البلده
المنكوبه اثر الزلزال المدمر
الدمار في كل مكان وناجون يتجرعون الام
فقدان عائلاتهم واقاربهم يحاولون استيعاب
حجم الخسائر الكبيره التي حلت بهم نحن
نبرك تحت هيك ما في اي مشكله بس اطفال
نساء
المصاب اللي طالعناه من تحت التراب يعني
ردود كذا هلق نزلت انا اولادي على المشفى
جسمه كله ازرق يعني اكثر من 270 بناء 270
بناء انهدموا على الارض تماما اكثر من
الفناء خارج كان يعني لا يصلح للسكن انا
3900 عائله لا تملك اي ماوى
في حقول بالقرب من المباني المدمره نصبت
بعض الخيام لايواء المنكوبين وقسم اخر
افترش ارضيه صاله رياضيه بانتظار اي
مساعدات قد تخفف من معاناتهم
عندي انا شهيد الحمد لله
وضعنا كتير تعبان
جنديرس هي المنطقه الاكثر كارثيه وتضررا
من الزلزال وفق التقارير وهو ما تعكسه
شكاوى ونداءات سكانها الذين يطالبون
بمساعدات عاجله تساعدهم على الصمود امام
الكارثه التي حلت بهم
وين المساعده
ملوك الشيخ العربيه
[موسيقى]
20 متطوعا بين معلما وطبيب يجمعهم الطبخ
والعمل الانساني لمساعده اكثر من 1500
ضحيه من الزلزال في جنديرس بسوريا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هون هون
يارب
عليك خمس دقائق قولي يا رب
[موسيقى]
خلص خلص
يه
في ظل الدمار الكبير الذي لحق المباني
والمنازل في حلب السوريه يعاني ناجون من
البرد القارس وانخفاض درجات الحراره ما
دفع بعض المتطوعين الى اطلاق حمله تبرع
بملابس دافئه للناجين سيما الاطفال منهم
لبسه لبسه السياره
شهد تركيا حمله اعتقالات جديده وطالت اخر
عمليه بهذا الخصوص مقاوله احد المباني
المدمره في كهرمان مرعش حيث جرى اعتقاله
في منطقه بودروم يذكر ان السلطات التركيه
تشنت مؤخرا اعتقالات المقاولين ورجال
الاعمال بسبب عيوب ومخالفات في المباني
المنهاره جراء الزلزال
تسابق السلطات التركيه الزمن لاواء منكوبي
الزلزال بتخصيص فضاءات مفتوحه لنصب الخيام
ملعب كره قدم بكرمان مرعش تحول الى مخيم
للمتضررين
الى انين فاقدين وفزع مفجوعين طابور من
الجائعين المتلهفين لمعرفه مصيرهم احتضنت
الخيام الجميع باستثناء محمد واولاده
سيبيتون بالعراء اليوم
بسبب نقص الخيام ما حصلنا خيمه لانه
الزلزال ضرب 10 ولايات عشر ولايات يعني
عدد ليس بالقليل كل ولايه بتطلع مليونين
نسمه مليون نسمه يعني اكبر دوله ما
بتستطيع تغطي بين مساعدات الانقاذ او
المساعدات الانسانيه والحمد لله يعني
الحكومه التركيه ما قصرت
يلهو الاطفال على امل ان ينسوا ازمه ستؤثر
عليهم مستقبلا كما يقول مختصون احمد اخرج
قريبه وزوجته من تحت الانقاض لم يلحق على
ابنهما الذي فارق الحياه يعيش في هذه
الخيمه 13 فردا من عائلته والله نحن كنا
نايمين انا ومرتين حسينا بزنزال يعني بس
احنا فكرنا بنومنا يعني بنام
بدا الزلزال هنا زلزل البشر والحجر قبل ان
يتركهم في العراء خارج منازلهم يسكنون
الخيامه ويتلقون المساعدات من جهات محليه
ودوليه
لاجل غير معلوم عبد المحسن الحربي العربيه
قهرمان مرعش
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
يا عمري
تمام
[موسيقى]
جديدين لتسهيل عمل الوكالات التي تدعم
جهود الاغاثه في سوريا
اهلا بكم قالت بريطانيا انها ستصدر
ترخيصين جديدين ليصبح من الاسهل على
وكالات المساعده التي تدعم جهودا الاغاثه
في سوريا العمل دون انتهاك عقوبات تستهدف
نظام السوري وداعميه اوضح وزير الدوله
للتنميه البريطاني اندروميتشل في بيان ان
عقوباتي بلاده لا تستهدف المساعدات
الانسانيه او الغذاء او الامدادات الطبيه
مشيرا الى ان المتطلبات الحاليه لمنح
تراخيصها فرديه ليست عمليه دائما في اثناء
الاستجابه للازمات
بعد مضي اكثر من اسبوع على الزلزال المدمر
الذي ضرب سوريا وتركيا ما تزال فرق
الانقاذ تنجح في الوصول الى احياء تحت
الانقاض حيث شهدت الساعات الاربعه
والعشرين الماضيه نجاه عده اشخاص من تحت
الركاب
بعد 222 ساعه في ولايه قهرمان مرعش فرق
الانقاذ تنتشر التركيه مليكه على قيد
الحياه
ايضا كتبت لهما الحياه بعد تسعه ايام تحت
ركام منزلهما بها طاي كينسوار
كذلك استطاعت هذه الطفله النجاه في قهرمان
مرعش بعد صمود اسبوع تحت الانقاظ
[موسيقى]
فاطمه جون انظت 212 ساعه محاصره قبل ان
تخرج حيه ترزق من تحت الحطام
[موسيقى]
لم يكن باستطاعه الطبيب عبد الباسط خليل
مساعده زوجته وطفلته بعد ان علقتاه تحت
الانقاض في لحظات الزلزال الاولى فقد كان
يحمل على عاتقه اسعاف وانقاذ من يمكن
انقاذه من المصابين في ريفيدلب
هذه النظره شبيهه بتلك التي راقب فيها
منزله يتكون فوق عائلته اثناء الزلزال
حينها خرج من مشفاه فرا ليصدم بهول المنظر
لم يكن يسمح الوقت حينها للطبيب عبد
الباسط خليل ان يهرع لانقاذ زوجته وطفلته
الوحيده فالمشفى بدا يمتلئ بالمصابين
وقتها اختار ان يكون الطبيب للزوج والاب
لشعور كتير صعب بس ننتقل الانسانيه هي
بتجبرك انه تساعد المصابين ولو كان زوجتك
وبنتك تحت الانقاض بس ما بيطلع بايدك شيء
انت لم تسرق الكارثه عائله الطبيب فحسب
فمسقط راسه مدينه الاتارب شمال حلب كانت
احدى اكثر المدن المتضرره بالزلزال وخساره
مئات الارواح
ومع تجاوز عدد الضحايا في سوريا
3500 قتيل تنعكس صوره ما الت اليه الاوضاع
في المنطقه المنكوبه شمالي سوريا على
ملامح وجه الطبيب وصوته
الناس تعتبر ان الطبيب هو البطل في كل
مواقف وبينسوا انه هو انسان مثل مثله
وعنده عيله وعنده اطفال لم ينفي عبد
الباسط تعبه ومواجهه لكنه لم ينفي ايضا ان
الاطباء هنا قاوموا مشاعرهم رغم حجم
خسائرهم واصبحوا اليوم بحاجه لمن يداويهم
قالت وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه ان
التقديرات الامريكيه تتماشى مع تقديرات
الامم المتحده بان سيف العدل العضو البارز
في تنظيم القاعده موجود في ايران وكان
تقرير امامي جديد افاد بان سيف العدل اصبح
الان زعيم تنظيم القاعده بعد مقتل ايمن
الظواهر في ضربه امريكيه العام الماضي
ورصدت الولايات المتحده مكافاه قدرها 10
ملايين دولار لمن يدلي بمعلومات تؤدي
لاعتقال او قتل سيف العدل
فان تقييمنا يتوافقوا مع تقييم الامم
المتحده التقييم الذي يشير الى ان سيف
العدل مقيم في ايران وعندما تعلقوا الامر
بوجوده هناك اي ان توفر طهران ملاذا امنا
للقاعده فهذا مجرد مثال اخر على دعم ايران
الواسع النطاق للارهاب وعلى انشطاتها
المزعزعه للاستقرار في الشرق الاوسط وما
وراءه
اعلن وزير الدفاع الالمانيه بوروس
بيستوريوس بعد اجتماع لوزراء دفاع دول
الحلف في بروكسل اعلن عزم المانيا ارسال
خمسه عشره دبابه من نوع الى اوكرانيا اكد
الوزير الالماني انه سيتم تسليم الدبابات
خلال الاسبوع الاخير من مارس وكان وزراء
دفاع المانيا هولندا دينمارك اعلنوا ان
اوكرانيا ستتلقى في الاشهر المقبله ما لا
يقل عن 100 دبابه واحد اي 5 وهي مدرعات
مستعمله تم تجديدها
اكد الممثل الامريكي الخاص برام روبرت
مالي ان الادله تتزايد على استخدام
الطائرات المسيره الايرانيه في المنطقه
ومن جانب روسيا في حرب هذا اوكرانيا اضاف
مالي على تويتر ان ذلك يحدث رغم ان النظام
الايراني ينفي ذلك باستمرار جاء ذلك
تعقيبا على تقرير نشرته المخابرات
العسكريه الامريكيه يؤكد استخدام روسيا
مسيرات ايرانيه مسلحه في اوكرانيا
اعلنت البعثه الروسيه في الامم المتحده
انها ستدعو الى اجتماع لمجلس الامن يوم
الثاني والعشرين من فبراير لمناقشه تفجير
خط الغاز نورت ستريم وقالت البعثه الروسيه
انه ستتم دعوه مجلس الامن لانعقادي
لمناقشه تخريب الخط ياتي ذلك بعد تحقيق
استقصاء للصحافه الامريكي سيمور هيرش اكد
خلاله ان الولايات المتحده وضعت متفجرات
على الخط اثناء مناورات في بحر البلطيق ثم
فجرتها لاحقا
حذر وزراء دفاع حلف شمال الاطلسي خلال
الاجتماعي في بروكسل حذروا بيلاروسيا من
عواقب التورط بحرب اوكرانيا كما اعلنوا عن
رفع الانفاق العسكري من قيمه الناتج
المحلي لكل دوله وبحث الوزراء ما اذا كان
الهدف الحالي بنفاق اثنين في المئه من
الناتج المحلي وهو امر كاف خصوصا مع
اندلاع الحرب في اوكرانيا
عقد رئيس الوزراء المصري مصطفى مدبولي
اجتماعا مع وفد من ممثلي عده شركات تركيا
هو الاول من نوعه منذ عشر سنوات وقال مجلس
الوزراء في بيان ان ممثلي شركات التركيه
عرضوا ضخ استثمارات جديده في مصر بما يقرب
من 500 مليون دولار مؤكدين على جاذبيه سوق
الاستثمار في مصر وفق البيان
يبحث مجلس الامن التابع للامم المتحده
مشروع قرار سيطالب اسرائيل بالوقف الفوري
والكامل لجميع الانشطه الاستيطانيه في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله وقال
دبلوماسيون انه من المرجح ان يصوت المجلس
المكون من 15 عضوا يقرر صوت الاثنين على
النص الذي صاغته الامارات بالتنسيق مع
الفلسطينيين وكانت حكومه رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو منحت الاحد
الماضي تراخيص باثر رجعي لتسعه مواقع
سلطانيه في الضفه الغربيه واعلنت عن بناء
عدد كبير من المساكن الجديده في
المستوطنات القائمه
في نهايه النشره هذا تذكير بالعناوين
حقوقيون يستعجلون ارسال فرق تقييم الكوارث
الى شمال سوريا وينتقدون استجابه الامم
المتحده
في تركيا حمل تعتقالات جديده لمقاولين
بتهمه الغش ومخالفه معايير البناء
وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه تؤكد ان سيف
العدل المقيم في ايران هو زعيم القاعده
الجديد
ولمتابعه ملفات العربيه والمزيد من
الاخبار وتحليلات زوروا موقعنا العربيه
وايضا مسح الكود الظاهر على الشاشه نلقاكم
بعد قليل الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]